c'est par tous
ses consorts
[Musique]
dont j'entendais supérieur derrière
louis aragon mais ce serait pas un peu
la dernière là bas si si si c'est
normalement la dernière semaine il ya
deux semaines j'accepte que vous nommez
ya de l'extra mal à ces salons mais tu
es passé une tête j'ai vu la lumière y
avait du monde partout au dessus du
court vous êtes payés évidemment à mais
bon ça joue un petit peu mais vous
inquiétez pas c'est surtout parce que je
kiffe
benjamin on sent que c'est l'été il fait
beau il fait chaud alors même si le pote
les politiques jouent les prolongations
dans les matinales bas je pense qu'il
ferait bien de prendre tout vacances
quand même mais aussi
les oui ça va permettre à tout le monde
de souffler un peu beaucoup et surtout
aux journalistes qui ont vraiment besoin
d'un petit widget
dis-je diaz vous êtes prête sous la
dernière législative les législatures
l'art en valeur leurs valorisations
pardon des maires de saint-hyacinthe
études vous êtes engagé en politique
jean-françois pocket copie
est en tout cas y en a un qui se voit
déjà en vacances sur une petite plage en
italie cette invite les stars des
républicains voilà aujourd'hui vraiment
je pense que dans l'intérêt du public
sur un beau sursaut éducatif l'inflation
est due aux facteurs les budgets des
communes ce toujours excédentaire en
fonctionnement sébastien chevalier du
rassemblement national tu es invité des
4 vérités je peux vous dire qu'il a
envie d'en découdre le mouv luc
mélenchon près ministre jamais jean luc
mélenchon premier mito toujours
mais bon ce qui est sûr c'est que quand
ils en trouvent une bonne main il lâche
pas la ferme de sébastien non mais
jean-luc mélenchon tout le monde a
compris qu'il sera jamais premier
ministre éventuellement premier mytho on
n'est pas comme aujourd'hui mélenchon
qui au lieu d'être ministre pour moi les
premiers mytho
[Musique]
contrairement aux journalistes michel
barnier est en pleine forme et ça s'est
vu sur france info il est toujours très
pertinent dans ses propos
[Rires]
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
michel barnier et on finit avec un petit
jeu à vous trouver la différence entre
tubes et doudou bonjour 1 2 3 soleil
et françois ruffin sur lci dimanche
dernier vous savez je m'amuse avec vous
comptons jusque 3 1 2 3
et bien parier sur vulgaire oui
bon benjamin sais pas si vous savez mais
je suis un très grand fan de vous je
voulais jamais dit cette saison et va
commencer parce que faire autant
d'antennes en articulant aussi peu c'est
très fort franchement allez vous
remercie à la sortie c'est par là bas je
vous taquine sur vous n'êtes pas plus à
plein de laurence boccolini est pas mal
aussi dans le domaine
[Musique]
et oui dans tout le monde veut prendre
sa place laurence boccolini a l'habitude
de présenter les candidats pré faut
juste faire gaffe aussi à la
prononciation des villes ça peut prêter
à confusion véronique elle vient de
montaigu vendée lé secrétaire delphine
montigny en gohelle elle est directrice
d'école
et enfin frédéric fans de freddie
mercury il vient de baisers
je pensais voulait dire quoi j'ai
regardé en que les chaînes d'info et je
suis pas sherlock holmes mais je crois
qu'ils sont bien fêter la fin de saison
celle du fn c'est donc un moment
historique et vous les posez là excusez
moi ton à voix sur bfm tv en direct
transforme les excuser moi ton avoir à
tout cas ce qu'on peut dire c'est que la
régie 2c news est au taquet dès le matin
il y en a qui restent propres qu'il
arrive c'est les rappels des titres avec
simon guida
[Applaudissements]
ça arrive à tout le monde en tout cas
ils ont réglé le bug en deux secondes
on recommande l'autorité au
20h de tf1 on a découvert une immense
tour en chine aménagé en site d'escaladé
hypersécurisée d'accord peut supporter
jusqu'à 2 tonnes même si vous étiez 4
sur cette corde elle ne casseraient pas
franchement moi qui avais pas trop la
confiance là je suis rassuré de ouf ne
t'inquiète pas au pire si tu tombes tu
atterris si par terre et j'ai maté les
apprentis aventuriers sur w9 j'ai suivi
l'équipe des jaunes dans laquelle y
avait un état d'esprit warrior ii conçu
à preuve de coordination et de
communication doit absolument remporter
cette épreuve voilà tous les moyens de
gagner est d'arriver à la victoire ouais
et rappelez vous les jeunes surtout
communication garde léon m'ba comme ça
vas-y en effet mis le paquet
bernard
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal il s'est passé pas mal de
choses aussi sur les réseaux benjamin
bajeux suis je mens menton sur les
réseaux bah oui je sais mais je vous
mets tout mêlé mais quand même un petit
peu là bon c'est un petit tour j'adore
s'est montrée vacances avant l'heure
c'est parti ça métaux dérives
sinon bah au moins ce mec n'a pas oublié
de mouiller la nuque avant de plonger à
la nuque
bonne ambiance à nice aussi je crois
même qu'il va bientôt y avoir une petite
fête des voisins
[Musique]
alors si vous allez au fast-food
attention à pas non plus commander tout
ce que vous dit votre fils bonsoir deux
grognards
un maxi bruit un maxi brrr
avec convivial dans ce camping à
brignoles où il ya une belle amitié qui
vient de naître
à
ruffec bonne nouvelle en c b a pas
encore dit son premier mot mais c'est
tout comme
[Musique]
et enfin passer un bel été mais faites
gaffe à pas pu quand même en ce moment
une un sport en roue libre
[Musique]
l'ancien nazi